- Good morning Believe Nation,
today's message is catch
ideas over you David Lynch.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- An idea comes and you see it
and you hear it and you know it.
- How does it come?
- It comes like on a TV in your mind.
(laughter)
- You know there's a
line I've always loved
of Leonard Cohen, he said if I knew where
the good songs came from, I
would go there more often.
- Absolutely.
People we don't do
anything without an idea
so there's beautiful gifts.
And I always say you desiring an idea
is like a bait on a hook.
It can pull them in.
If you catch an idea that you love,
that's a beautiful, beautiful day
and you write that idea
down so you won't forget it.
And that idea that you caught
might just be a fragment
of the whole whatever it
is that you're working on.
But now you have even more bait.
Thinking about that small fragment,
that little fish, will bring in more
and they'll come in and they'll hook on.
And more and more come in and pretty soon
you might have a script, or a chair,
or a painting or an idea for a painting.
- But they come as
in small-
- More often than not, small fragments.
I like to think of it
as in the other room,
the puzzle is all together.
But they keep flipping in
just one piece at a time.
- In the other room-
- Over there.
(laughter)
- In a sense David, there's
always another room somewhere.
- That's a beautiful thing to think about.
- Let's think about it a bit.
- No you think about it.
(laughter)
- The best ideas come
when you can see a pattern
that other people can't see.
When you can combine
multiple things into one
and that combination's
never been done before.
If I look at what I've done
here with Toronto Dance Salsa,
we're a salsa dancing school,
a lot of people have done
dance instruction before
but they haven't done it
in the way that I want to do it.
What we're starting to
really introduce hard core
is story telling and life
advice into the classes.
So that you're coming not just to
learn a new set of moves,
but to be a more confident,
more fulfilled human being.
And so I need to teach the
instructors not just about
how to teach a right turn
or how to teach a Coca-Cola,
or how to teach cross-_,
any of those moves,
but also how to be a guide.
How do give people confidence,
how to make people push
beyond their comfort zone.
When people come to a class here,
they're in for a life changing experience.
My goal for all of the instructors is
I want each instructor to be
among the all time favorite
instructors, teachers, of
every student that comes in.
If you think about your life,
you've had a favorite instructor,
a favorite teacher growing up,
maybe it was your grade
eight science teacher,
and you forgot all the other
instructors and teachers
in your life, I want that person,
if you come to take a class
at Toronto Dance Salsa,
I want my instructor to be your
favorite teacher of all time.
And that comes when you make an impact on
the person's life beyond
just teaching them a move.
So why's this important?
How did I come up with this great idea?
It's not really my idea,
people have already done this.
If you look at Bob Ross
and he teaches people
how to paint, people love Bob Ross
not just because of his
painting instruction,
but because of the life advice and wisdom
that he gave in his classes.
Russell Simmons does it
in his fitness classes.
Tony Robbins does it in his events.
Priest and pastors do it at
their churches every weekend
around the world.
This model already exists.
I'm just bringing it to the salsa world,
to the dance instruction world,
'cause nobody has done it before.
And so while it may look
like some stroke of genius,
now when people are walking out of class
and they've had a profound life experience
on top of learning some dance moves,
people can give me the
credit all they want.
But it's really just I'm
pulling from the things
that I'm interested in.
I'm learning from these people that I've
put on my YouTube channel
saying how do we apply this
to our business?
It's not that I'm super genius,
you could do it for yourself as well.
Look at what has made people successful.
Watch the top 10 videos, learn from people
who've had massive success in their fields
and then think what can I learn from them?
What can I learn from the most successful
Mercedes-Benz dealership in the world
and how do I apply that
to my golf business?
It's those connections
that other people haven't
thought about that will make
you massively successful.
If you are just starting
up in the business,
I recommend modeling success.
If you don't know how to do something,
modeling success is one of
your fastest ways to do it.
Learn from people who've come before you,
model what worked for them
and apply it to your business.
And it works great for
people within your industry
as a start, if you're in software,
go learn from Bill Gates.
If you're in whatever industry,
learn from the person in
your industry who's made it.
But don't let that limit you.
Also learn from people who
you look up to and respect.
If you love Jay Z and
you're a videographer
or you're an author, what
can you learn from Jay Z
to make you a better writer?
What can you learn from Jay Z
to make you a better dancer?
to make you a better plumber electrician?
'Cause you can.
And when you figure out that connection,
you'll be the only one in
your industry doing it.
And you're going to stand
up and rise above the rest.
So when you get these ideas,
when you surround yourself
with more than just
the typical way of doing
something in the business,
then you're going to catch
these little pieces of ideas
and test them in your company.
And not all of them are going to work,
in fact most of them probably won't work.
But you'll find a few that
make you come alive, that
you really, really love
and are passionate about and
that work with the audience
and people really connect with.
And when you go all in on those things,
that's what's really going
to explode your business.
That's what's really going
to allow you to do that thing
that only you can do that no other plumber
or electrician or dancer can model.
That's what's really going to be the thing
that sets you apart and
allows you to build something
that's both personally fulfilling
and has a huge impact that lets you go out
and make a lot of money
with your company as well.
The best ideas come from
when you can combine things
in a pattern that other people don't see.
Start looking from other industries
and applying it to your business today.
So the question today is I'm
curious what have you learned
from a different business
that you've applied
to your company where it
seemed totally off beat,
totally different, totally
outside industry norms
and it worked?
Super curious to find out,
please share it down
in the comments below.
And we'll join in discussion.
I always wanted to give a
quick shout out to Sandra.
Sandra thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
for entering the book contest,
for making those amazingly
delicious Your One Word cookies.
They were awesome and I really
appreciate your support.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one word is
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ And espresso keep me going
Hey Believe Nation, thank
you so much for watching.
If you want to learn
more about this subject,
get a little bit deeper on it,
I'm going to share some extra bonus clips
that I hope you'll enjoy.
- Number one for me, life lesson,
is the ideas matter.
The people say of course ideas matter,
what kind of stupid life
lesson is it that ideas matter?
The truth of the matter is,
this is both under and over appreciated.
Most people think every idea's a good idea
as long as they had it.
The truth of the matter is,
not every idea is a good idea,
not every idea matters,
and not every idea should be pursued.
And if you're in a field like
I am or was of innovation,
not every idea is a good idea,
even if it strikes you
that way on first plush.
In fact most people are lucky to have
one idea that really
matters in their whole life.
That's not a criticism
but earth shattering,
life changing ideas are
very few and far between.
Research insights, investment
insights, innovations.
A good idea needs to be
cherished and nurtured.
- Success is
not something you pursue.
Success is a matter of
becoming a personal value.
We should be pursing money,
we should pursue purpose,
we should pursue vision for ourselves
and for our countries,
for our communities.
We should be not pursing things,
we need to pursue ideas.
I always say that there are three types of
people in the world.
There's poor people, there's rich people,
and there's wealthy people.
Poor people talk about money all the time.
Rich people talk about things.
Wealthy people, they talk about ideas.
Rich people, poor people
and wealthy people think differently.
For example, poor people
they pursue money.
Rich people pursue things.
Wealthy people pursue ideas.
Constantly there's a
different way of thinking.
I hope that the third world countries
and the young people of our nation
will become ideas people.
Ideas control the world, not money.
Ideas attract money.
So I think if we minimize
this desire to get money
and elevate the creativity of new ideas,
we'll find that financial results
will naturally flow to it.
Bill Gates didn't pursue
money, he pursued an idea.
Steven Jobs, the late Steven Jobs,
who invented the Apple
computer and the iPhone.
He never went after money,
he developed an idea.
If you think of all the
wealthy people in the world,
it was ideas that made
them wealthy, not money.
So I think we need to
switch it, reverse it.
Don't pursue money and
then try to get an idea.
Get an idea and money will pursue the idea
and you become a byproduct
as far as wealth.
- What is the word
entrepreneur mean to you?
- When somebody can take
an idea and make it real.
An entrepreneur could
be a business person,
could be an artist, could be a musician,
anybody who can have an idea
and turn it into reality.
- And how did you do that?
- I dedicated myself to it.
When I was 22 years old, I promised myself
that I would work my tail off until
the age of 30 at a minimum to
succeed as an entrepreneur.
That was extremely important
because I had a lot of
failure along the way.
- Right the first company
you started failed.
- Yeah actually and
then there was a company
that I didn't even start that I failed at.
So I really had two failures
before I succeeded with GoPro.
- How do those failures drive you today?
- At the time they scared me.
Failure isn't easy, it
wasn't like I thought
oh cool I failed.
Success has taught me that
one of the most important
things an entrepreneur
can have is perseverance.
The dedication, a willingness to fail,
pick yourself up again
and give it another shot.
Because if you don't have that,
if you don't have that grit,
you're going to get run over.